with tongle me you can set the minimum
number of times visitors must propose
when requesting a meeting through your
page here's how to set it sign in to
tongle me and make sure you're on home
in the top
menu click the availability icon and
then select
availability scroll below the calendar
view to where it says visitors must
propose at
least this is where you'll set your
minimum
times I've set mine to two which means
visitors will be asked to propose at
least two times when requesting a
meeting through my
page you can set this up to five or as
low as 1 note that if you set it to one
people will be able to direct book you
through your page that means they'll be
able to pick one time slot and book you
on the spot however to prevent you from
being spammed you'll receive an email
confirmation and the meeting will not be
added to your calendar until you accept
it
once you've completed your changes be
sure to
save and you're done